It's harder than a frog to be able to stop a battle midway through.
Hey, you know, I
was about to cut off the head of an air drink with just a little bit of art Don't get hung up on
Mercia gambling is no more than a local lord
Look at the war situation broadly
I should live a fulfilling war life
in the eastern land  Essel Red's Koedo gate is
showing disturbing movements
Please lend us your strength to Tobu Lease I'll
take it, but I won't forget who I'm
going to play with here, right?  I'll
see with my own eyes what you're going to do and who you're going to become You're
still no one, even the king of England is a lad You know what I'm doing,
you'll be able to avoid war
Your path will have to be
paved in Chitose Just
like Aserat did, do
n't forget Your swearing has been bloody from the beginning